there's a Reddit post that's circulating
and it hit close to home because of what
I recommended
I'm curious who's seen this Reddit post
that I'm talking about it's related to
the speed run
is grunfeld really garbage at
intermediate level Hikaru and Levy said
so
I'm mid 1500s in Rapid and against D4
I've been thinking about switching to
the grunfeld I pulled up the Hikaru and
Levy to your list for intermediate
levels and they placed Greenfield in the
garbage tier
I don't get it if your opponent doesn't
know what they're doing you can just
destroy White's center right out of the
opening then afterwards there's a clear
plan where you march your queen side
pawns down the board and enjoy a nice
comfy two versus one
opening pressure and an obvious plan for
intermediate players that sounds like
the dream please what am I missing
so of course the grinfeld is my official
speedrun recommendation
so I have not seen Hikaru and Levy's
tier list but I feel very strongly that
the biggest misconception that a lot of
players have is that you somehow are
supposed to not study Theory as an
intermediate player let's say 1300 or so
that somehow the expectation is that you
don't need to study Theory yet and you
should choose an opening where you can
you know circumvent the need to know a
lot of theory and as I've been saying
really from the start I think this is
one of the biggest misconceptions that
stops a lot of players from improving
quickly not only do I think that and
I've become more radical on this front
to the point where now I basically think
that once you reach once you cross the
beginner level I'm not saying that as a
300 you should be learning chessable
courses although you should by the way
have a solid repertoire but once you hit
the intermediate level let's say 1200
chess.com rapid and above
you should absolutely dedicate the
whatever time you have
to learning theory and not only having a
clear repertoire and a clear
understanding of what you play but
actually memorizing
you know a good amount of theory and
memorizing the main lines as well as the
openings and the variations that your
opponents tend to play against you so I
really feel like people miss how much
knowing your openings as an intermediate
player gives you that boost and gives
you super comfortable positions almost
every game it changes your experience I
think a lot of players frustrations come
from the idea that because an opening
has a lot of theory that somehow an
intermediate level player can't learn it
which I think is just BS I don't think
that has any
it does not correspond to the truth at
all and nobody likes to hear this
because stunning openings is a drag
but hopefully the speedrun is helping
you
build up your opening repertoire and now
not saying it's impossible to succeed
without learning openings or that there
is like a quote-unquote correct way to
do it this is merely my experience of
helping people improve
and that's all there is to it
[Music]
okay we're black against Pavlov am from
Belarus
1865. definitely a good player
hopefully we don't get aborted nope very
good okay so we're finally I feel like
it's been ages since we've had a black
game
hopefully it will finally be able to get
a Mainline accelerated dragon now we
have faced the rosalimo a couple times
and now we're facing the open Sicilian
which is music to my ears I think this
is only our second accelerated dragon
of the entire speedrun
in the first one uh we faced the marozzi
bind which is the move C4 and in that
game I demonstrated a sideline system
that I find to be very effective at the
intermediate level where you basically
play Knight F6 before fion Kettering the
bishop but I'll review that after the
game right now we're facing Knight C3
which is of course the other main line
so here we don't have the space for any
Shenanigans we start by developing our
Bishop putting immediate pressure on the
Knight and white develops their Bishop
to E3 which is the continuation of the
main line a lot of players a lot of
newer players they tend to take on C6 in
this position which is an immediate big
concession and it's a big concession
because it allows black to capture
toward the center the B file can be used
by Black's Rook to pressure the B2 Pawn
particularly if White Castle's Queen
side and it's much easier to prepare the
central brake d75
so Bishop B3 is a no-brainer at the
higher levels and now there is an
important moment because
if you're a Mainline Dragon player then
you can go D6 here but the drawback of
D6 from an accelerated Dragon standpoint
is that it allows white to transition
into a Mainline dragon with the move F3
so the way to keep this uniquely
accelerated Dragon style is to first
develop the Knight to F6 you actually do
not push any of your Center pawns until
later in the game
potentially even until
four or five moves from now
yeah
and our opponent finally settles into a
bit of a think
so the main move here is Bishop F1 to C4
this is the most ambitious developing
move Queen D2
uh is not a main line it's a sideline
and as far as I know it's not a
particularly good sideline either
so let's think about this move for a
second Queen D2
well generally in all Dragon setups
any time the queen is moved from D1 you
should immediately be considering the
move Knight to G4 because if you can
trade your knight for White's dark squid
Bishop then Your Dragon Dark squared
Bishop operates uncontested which is
virtually always a good thing that's an
advantage for you so if you can root out
if you can root out
the dark squared Bishop you almost
instantly get a good position but it's
not always that simple because after
Knight G4
white cannot move the bishop because
then he loses the Knight on D4 which is
attacked twice what white can do after
Knight G4 is take on C6 which as we've
already discussed is generally a
concession but after we recapture white
can shift the dark squared Bishop over
to D4 and while giving away your knight
for the bishop is good trading dark
squared Bishops in Dragon setups isn't
always that great that's a lot more
double edged than giving away
your knight for the bishop so in that
resulting position we have to come up
with a response
and I have a really interesting idea I
already have to settle into a bit of a
think here
so
there's some interesting tactics that
occur after Bishop D4 there
yeah of course in that position first of
all after Knight takes C6 we can play DC
and engineer a queen trade but that
seems like a pretty boring option which
leads to a largely symmetrical end game
that seems
pretty anti-climactic
we also have the possibility of striking
at the center with the move D5 so I'm
actually struggling this is definitely
something to look up after the game I'm
struggling to figure out a satisfactory
response after Knight G4 Knight takes C6
BC and Bishop D4
because if you play E5 in that position
the bishop slides one square further to
C5
and as a result we're not able to Castle
and we're not able to kick the bishop
away with D6 because that square will be
defended twice by the queen and by the
bishop
by the queen and by the bishop
so let's think about this for a couple
more moments give me 30 seconds in
silence
definitely something I should know
but something I I've never checked Queen
D2 here has never been played against me
you know what I think we should do what
I think we should do is not overreact or
do anything crazy I think we should just
Castle
I think when in doubt you should just
continue your development I'm not sure
how to assess Knight G4 and as we've
discussed you do not want to play D6
because that enables white to transition
into the dragon with F3 now why what is
the rationale behind keeping your Pawn
on D7 well the idea is that if white
insists on playing a Mainline Dragon
setup then you will be able to play D5
in one Fell Swoop and that is often
you know without any question a good
thing for black now white has done what
I thought he would do he's castled
queenside and there's a good reason that
you need to play F3 in the mainline
dragon that is indeed to avoid Knight G4
how has the situation changed as a
result of White's last move well one
thing I'm noticing is that the king and
the queen are now aligned what does that
entail well we need to recalculate
Knight G4 because just because a move
doesn't work in one position doesn't
mean it doesn't work in another so what
happens if we play Knight G4 here well
the bishop still can't move so if y
takes on C6 and then plays Bishop D4 we
have something very exciting in that
resulting position we have the bishop
pin we have Bishop to H6 pinning the
queen and the King
now that doesn't win the queen because
white can block that pin with the move
F4 F to F4 but if we keep calculating I
think black has a winning move after F4
very good so after F4 who can spot
blacks ensuing Crusher
it literally ends the game after F4 E5
very good Pawnee 7 to E5
hitting the pawn on F4 and threatening
Bishop takes F4 but also attacking the
bishop on D4 it's a double attack it's a
simple double attack and white loses at
least a piece
so the coast is clear we can go Knight
G4 and we spent a lot of time on these
couple moves so we'll have to speed up a
little bit
now after Knight C6 BC Bishop D4 Bishop
H6 White's relative relatively speaking
best move is to drop the bishop back to
E3 but then we get sort of an ideal
scenario we take with the Knight
we ruin White's Pawn structure that is
like a dream scenario for us the other
thing that our opponent can do is move
the bishop along this diagonal but as
I've mentioned at the start when White
Castle's Queen side and the B file is
open like this it often spells almost
immediate Doom for white because we get
such an easy attack down the B file
for instance if he plays Bishop F4 we
can't go Rook B8 because that square is
controlled
but what we can do is deploy Our Queen
to B6 that's another positive benefit of
putting the Knight on G4 it actually
attacks the F2 Pawn which is a really
easy thing to miss
so Queen B6 seems like a great move to
consider
but it's far from the only possible way
to develop our attack
we also could very well consider the
move E5 trying to chase the bishop away
from that diagonal and also enabling us
to play Rook B8 and we could even play
the move Queen d8 A5 which is a more
typical attacking move in the dragon
setup
uh when the B file is closed
but Bishop D4 is such a natural move and
he plays it and here we go Bishop G7 to
H6 will respond instantly let's see if
our opponent smells a rat he doesn't he
goes F4 he walks right into the losing
line so again this is the position we
were talking about if you're you know
watching on YouTube and you had a hard
time visualizing the line we were
talking about earlier this is the exact
position in which I asked everybody to
find the move
so again the queen is pinned and this is
the natural move E5 should occur to you
pretty much automatically
because you should notice that the F4
Pawn has to be attacked and the best way
to attack something is with another Pawn
and this is the power of the pin the
fact that the pawns simply cannot move
it's as if the pawn on F4 doesn't exist
and okay the game is not totally over
White
can cut his losses
well not really but the best way to cut
the losses is to play Bishop takes E5
and after Knight takes E5 to not
recapture the Knight but that's an
incredibly depressing outcome we're up a
full piece and we'll still have to
demonstrate a good deal of technique the
Knight on E5 in the resulting position
is not that easy to evacuate to safety
because it's only Escape square is back
through G4 and potentially white could
cover that square with H3 so we'll have
to finesse that a little bit to make
sure that all our pieces reach home base
safely but
that's a secondary problem clearly black
is winning and some people would just
resign here Bishop Queen E2 okay that
doesn't help
that doesn't help but we need to be very
careful we need to avoid a very tempting
but wrong move
so the tempting thing to do here is to
say well before taking the bishop we
might as well snag the pawn and F4 with
check
but you actually have to calculate that
right there's a lot going on here you
can't just make a move based on General
considerations and if you look at that
carefully after King B1 it turns out
that Bishop takes F4 is a grave mistake
because if we take on D4 then white will
take the Knight and then if we take
White's night the that Bishop that we
put on F4 is now hanging
so we should keep the bishop on H6 and
take on D4 immediately
now if Queen takes Knight then we take
whitesnite and we're chilling we
absolutely do not need this F4 Pawn
unless of course white takes on D4 in
that case we will take on F4 with check
not a single one of those arrows has
been drawn correctly but you get the
point
yeah queen queen E2 merely hastens
White's defeat yeah this is going to be
a total disaster because this Pawn on C3
is such a destructive force
it's essentially used as a battering ram
forcibly shattering White's protective
cover on the queen side so our ensuing
attack is going to be decisive within
five moves I think if we play our cards
right
because if white plays B3 which I think
is most people's natural reaction to a
pawn like this well that doesn't help
because we have the lobster mate if we
can get our Queen to A3 and we can get
our Queen to A3 either via E7 or via A5
either move works and that basically
ends the game immediately the king I
guess could run into the center but
remember the white is down a piece to
begin with so there's not much to talk
about here
if white plays BC then White's Queen
side is completely shattered and we
could attack that C3 Pawn with a move
like Queen d8 to F6
simultaneously hitting F4 as well
or queen A5 which I would assume is the
more natural move
if white does not respond which is in
fact what our opponent has done here I
would not recommend
hastily taking on B2 this is an
important attacking point now again when
you're up a piece you can basically do
whatever the heck you want but if we
want to play clinically you this Pawn is
a great asset we want white to be the
one to play BC because after CB black
white can use that pawn as an umbrella I
call it the sort of umbrella defensive
method you've probably seen it before
and essentially tucked the king under
the pawn where it'll be much much harder
for us to get to the King which is using
our own Pawn as a protective cover and
that's the most effective protective
cover because you cannot capture your
own Pawn
so what is the best way to force white
to take on C3
or to play B3 we want to get white
essentially to decide how he wants to
play on the queen side so that we could
in turn properly arrange our attacking
forces well we could play Rook B8
but I think leading with the queen is an
even better idea because we know that
the queen is the piece in this case that
can deliver the Checkmate if white plays
B3 so my preferred move is Queen to B6
we are threatening made in one but there
is a secondary threat which can be very
easy to miss and that is Queen to E3
check when you're attacking you have to
pay attention to both sides of the board
right and Hess points this out a lot
very often players kind of
subconsciously section off the board and
only look at moves on the side of the
board where they're attacking but you
always have to keep the entire board in
your kind of Mind's Eye okay so let's
try to find the fastest path to
Checkmate here if we play the move Queen
to B4
then the bad news for us is that that is
not immediate made because white can
move the D Rook away
and then if we deliver a check on A3 the
king is able to run away through the
center now it's not going to run away
for long we could then for example we
could take the pawn on A2 or we could
even play the move D5 and open up the
other Bishop a discovery on White's
Queen but let's see if there's an if
there's a more efficient way for us to
Checkmate so we could throw in the check
on E3 Force the king back toward B1
and then drop the queen back to C5 how
about that well
frustratingly white still isn't mated
there white can play King A1 Queen A3
and Rook D1 to B1 which is a classic way
of Defending against the lobster mating
motif
so in that resulting position after Rook
B1 it actually might be even harder to
Checkmate the white king than it would
be if the king were to hide in the
center
so let's think about this for a second
maybe there's a middle ground that we
could adopt here
I have an interesting idea
of course all of this is completely
winning and you know this is all very
hypothetical because we're up a piece
and we could always just resort to the
simple strategy of taking all of our
opponents like Queen E3 and queen takes
F4 even that would be winning but why
prolong the game when we could go
straight for checkmate
so I think
what we should do here
hmm
it's interesting because it's so winning
but I'm trying to be surgically precise
here and it's not that simple actually
okay here's what we're gonna do
we are going to start
with the move Queen to C5
we're gonna start with a flexible move
Queen to C5
yeah we could also play A5 A4 and open
up the a file we could also play a5a4
and open up the Eightfold this is hard
it's hard to be ultra precise in a
completely winning position because
there's so many appetizing options Rook
F1 okay now
what we're going to do and by the way we
could still give that check on E3
but I guess then Queen C5 white can just
repeat moves my idea here was to delay
the check on A3 because the king wants
to go here anyway so that would kind of
be a waste of a move
instead if we're anticipating the white
king running toward the center well
logically the best thing to do would be
to open up the center
right if we can open up the center let's
say open up the D file then the king
will not find any measure of relief on
D1 so I think it's a perfect opportunity
for us to play D5 and an instructive
moment because a lot of players would
kind of automatically deliver this check
you can deliver this check anytime you
want so what's the purpose of delivering
it now especially when
the king is particularly vulnerable on
the Square and the F Pawn is still
pinned just kind of valuable otherwise
white could have met this move without
five
all right now well let's continue the
opening up at the center we don't have
to move our Bishop again don't play
automatically when you're this close to
Checkmate you can just play D take C4
because we're not afraid of Queen takes
H6 why does no other attackers on the
king side so in that case we just play e
takes D3 and the game is over
or we could play Queen a three check and
Bishop G4 check we could look for a
force mate there as well
but we don't need to
Bishop C4
okay now note that our Rooks are still
disconnected so Rook to d8 here would be
a blunder the queen is aimed at that
square always keep that in mind
right when your Rooks are not connected
you should be ultra careful about moving
your Rooks in general
there is a really cool idea that we
could play here it's a pretty sexy
sequence let me just calculate it for a
second before I talk about how I found
it
now the position is completely winning
everything wins here from the simple
Bishop to G7 to a check on A3 and I'm
sure there's some mating sequence there
but I actually think I see a forced mate
and it's a really really nice concept so
thinking logically right let's work
backwards to figure this move out Queen
A3 would be Checkmate if the white king
did not have access to the D file to the
D1 Square so it would be very very nice
if we could play Rook to d8 and if we
could play Rook to d8 then Queen A3
would be an Unstoppable threat white
would have simply no way to prevent the
black queen from reaching A1
so well what's stopping us from playing
Rook d8 it's the fact that the Rooks are
disconnected which means that moving the
bishop out makes a lot of sense but we
don't just want to move it out anywhere
because that gives wet a Tempo we would
like to make a move that forces white to
react to it and then play Rook d8 and as
many of you are noticing the best way to
do that is Bishop to G4
yeah
and as a matter of fact
what's kind of cool about this move
is that if white takes the bishop we
could play Rook 88 we could even play
Queen A3 check and I'm calculating a
force made in that line
I think there's a force made in that
line as well
King d8 uh King D1 Rook d a check
King E1 Queen C1 check but why bother
why bother especially when
this move is
you know waiting for us on a golden
platter doesn't matter which Rook by the
way absolutely does not matter but I'm
keeping this Rook on f8 so that Bishop
takes F7 is less of a headache
not that it would be a headache there
either
well Rook d8 Queen takes da was check
that's the problem
if we had played Rook T8 first queen
takes Rook would have been a check
and White's only way to Stave off
Checkmate is Bishop D3
but in that position we could end the
game
probably even Rook takes D3 is forced
mate
I mean everything wins there but we have
kind of a nice Manning sequence if we
really want to be fancy
now obviously King B1 Queen A3 is
Unstoppable man and that is a pattern
that everybody should be familiar with I
know Hikaru refers to it as Lobster
pincermate that's kind of caught on
and the kind of tactics that revolve
around the lobster pins are made are are
really important to understand
and um just to point out that Bishop D3
here the fastest mate is in fact Rook
takes D3
Pawn takes D3
Queen E3 check
again you can spot the mating patterns
here King B1 and you don't even need to
take the pawn just go Queen D2 and again
it's the lobster pincer made on B2
that's totally Unstoppable white gets
David off but you just take the rug
even faster is C2 check this is made in
two
it's actually made in two
yeah this is made in two or King B2 C1
equals Queen mate Discovery the Queens
defend each other
so a very easy game it was unfortunate
that our opponent blundered this quickly
but still more successful experiences
with the accelerated dragon
and again we're we're seeing that it's
the Sicilian that nobody studies at this
level and when you're on your own in a
sicilian bad things tend to happen to
you
okay so let's have a quick look
um and again you know that I can't we
don't have a guarantee that all the
games are going to be equally
interesting
but hopefully the the post game analysis
makes them worth it
okay just a moment
so
this is the first time that we have
faced Knight to C3 previously we faced
the morosi bind which is what most
Grandmasters play against the
accelerated
and you might remember that my
recommendation here is not Bishop G7
but instead to start with Knight F6
already setting a trap if white tries to
punish you by taking and going E5 you
have a fork on the king in the pawn
so of course Knight C3 is standard then
you trade and play D6 you do things in a
slightly weird move order in order to
lure the queen onto a vulnerable Square
why is it vulnerable because when you
feed and keto the bishop you're you're
often going to gain a Tempo because the
queen is going to have to move out of
the potential Discovery if I remember
correctly our first game in the open
Sicilian went something like our
opponent went here
and I think in this position our
opponent went Bishop to E3 which is a
big positional mistake who can remind me
why it's a big positional mistake and
this is also on theme
it's not that we have a win we can't win
the queen here
but we go Knight G4 this is kind of a
no-brainer if you're an accelerated
player because again trading the Knight
for the bishop is almost always a good
thing we have uncontested control
of Key Dark squares in the center I
think we played Bishop B6 here and we
kind of won a nice positional game so
you could refresh your memory that game
is on YouTube as well here uh in this
position after castles White's main move
is I'm pretty sure to move the queen
back Queen D3 Queen D3 and then to
develop the bishop and white is slightly
better if he handles this very precisely
but it's still a very playable position
where it's pretty easy to learn a lot of
the ideas anyways this is beside the
point we're facing Knight C3 Bishop E3
after Knight F6 the move Queen D2 which
I honestly yeah have never come across
and I'm looking at the engine and seeing
that castles is indeed the correct move
so we made the correct decision here
now why am I avoiding recommending the
mainline Dragon well the mainline dragon
and the accelerated Dragon are two
completely different animals although
the same animal they're the Dragon
but in terms of the positions that they
produce they could not be more different
essentially the only similarities that
you feel in Canada the bishop in when I
say Mainline Dragon some people might
not know what I mean so what I mean is
the sort of traditional Dragon where you
play D6 D4
and this is the entry point to the
nidorf which is A6 which I could have
recommended and the dragon is G6 it's
not that it's been refuted it hasn't
been refuted but it's a ridiculously
risky opening and you have to know loads
and loads of theory and you could still
get checkmated even if you know loads
and loads of theory also it's
theoretical standing right now is pretty
dubious and there have been a lot of
analysis done in the main lines so I
think players are more likely to study
the dragon from White's perspective than
the accelerated dragon
and the key distinction is that in the
the mainline Dragon white plays F3
and the main line goes Knight C6 Queen
D2 castles and you normally get opposite
side Catholic this is one main line and
then the other Main Line white first
develops the bishop to C4 to stop D5 I
think this is called the Hugo slot
attack but in this line where black
plays D5 this might be familiar to some
people who are watching this as the main
line the most popular line nowadays
white plays Bishop to D4 there's that
idea again where white tries to take
Black's fiancado Bishop out of
commission and often black is forced to
make this very undesirable move E5
closing down the diagonal for the bishop
and this takes a lot of the fun out of
the Dragon this line that you see right
here is incredibly popular among white
players and white is considered to be
better in in this line that's not really
subject to debate
and black often sacrifices this exchange
by the way although Anish giri in his
chest level course recommends the
relatively rare move rookie 8 but that's
beside the point
as we go back to the accelerated Dragon
the thing that's most important to
understand and this is a trap which even
Bobby Fischer fell into white could
essentially try to get the same type of
position and play the move F3 I think a
lot of players do make this move at a
lower level and after castles white
plays the move Queen D2 what is the
difference well the difference is that
we have not committed to the move D6 so
we can save a Tempo on that move and
play D5 in one Fell Swoop this exact
position would occur in the mainline
Dragon but it would be white to move in
this position and white would take on D5
with black to move there are no problems
at all you can play Knight takes Knight
and after
well after Queen takes night you have a
simple Discovery Knight takes C4 and
black is much better and if Bishop takes
Knight then you take the pawn on e4 and
clearly Black's position is very very
comfortable here I think something like
Queen A5 yields a great position white
structure is damaged our pieces are
coming out nicely and this is really
doesn't even compare to that other
position I could check the engine here
but we'll save that for another day
so that's the point right you're saving
a Tempo on D6
now the way that white could try to
punish you is by saying okay you don't
want to go D6 I'm going to take on C6
and play E5 myself and punish you for
not playing D6 but I I showed this line
I think in the previous accelerated
video and the point is you actually go
back to G8
all right this is a move you simply have
to know otherwise it might be hard to
get yourself to play this move and after
F4 you redeploy the Knight through the
other side of the board you play Knight
H6 and oftentimes the Knight reaches F5
pretty quickly
and because black has such a healthy
structure the you know relatively many
moves that you play with the same piece
that simply cannot be punished white can
play Queen D2 I mean the theory goes on
here and after black castles and White
Castles you can
disrupt this Pawn on E5 by playing even
the move D6 here is very very strong
and if white plays too materialistically
takes takes takes then black is going to
develop uh not just an initiative but
black wins The Exchange in this position
with what sequence of moves who can spot
the two moves which win material for
black
yeah Knight F5 forces The Rook back and
the bishop comes out to A6 and tosses
The Rook out of D3 so
this is a good application of the Knight
going from F6 to G8 to H6 eventually to
F5
so in any case these this is stuff that
we will I'm sure get to in more depth
but in this game we faced a different
kind of mistake the move Queen D2 and
here I think I responded very well so
let me
reiterate the logic behind not playing
Knight G4 here and that's a valuable
thing to remember
so the reason we don't play Knight G4 is
because of Knight takes C6
and yes I said that this structural
transformation typically favors black
but the extenuating circumstance here is
this very annoying move Bishop D4 and
it's annoying because we don't just want
to give away our Bishop for White's
Bishop this type of position is better
for white and that should be pretty
obvious to you especially if you have to
Castle White could just knock the Knight
away with F3 gain a tempo
and this type of position looks very
unappetizing because the bishop is an
integral part of our ability to attack
the white king once at Castle's Queen
side
now we have several ways to avoid that
and I was considering the movie five but
now after Bishop C5 we were just
paralyzed we're paralyzed we can't
Castle because it's illegal white
controls the f8 square we would just die
to play the move D6 but we can't do it I
mean it just blenders the plot we can't
really play D5 because that's defended
three times
and we can throw in a move like Bishop
H6 so what does that really do white
drops the queen back and our pieces are
stuck in no man's land and the Knight is
hanging and I don't see a way for us to
make this work
so these are the kinds of subtle points
that you find out when you play an
opening a lot right and so when you just
start playing an opening you're gonna
make a lot of mistakes they're gonna
face moves that you don't know so you
need to be patient with yourself that is
why I decided to Castle and I think that
was the correct decision
so here once again if White Castles then
we reach the game continuation and now
we play Knight G4 that's what happened
in the game I don't think white has any
good moves in this position if white
plays F3 we just talked about this black
plays D5 and we transpose into the line
that we just analyzed
and by the way if white plays well what
else can I do in this position I guess
white can take on D5 but then we take on
D5
and in the event of the mass trade look
at how our Pawn very nicely reaches C6
and supports the Knight you should
completely ignore this damage spawn
structure much more important is how
active our pieces are and if white tries
to play Bishop D4 here then because
white isn't castled yet
this reaches a completely different
position to the instance where white
plays Bishop D4 here these are two
completely different positions here were
castled white is uncastled whites play
this weakening move F3 a lot of things
are different the engine recommends E5
and after Bishop C5 there's some really
cool engine recommendations it even
gives Rook to B8 as a possibility
sacrificing The Exchange and one trap
that I've seen a lot of people fall into
this trap exists in other lines of the
Dragon you take back with a queen and if
White Castles oh let's defend the pawn
Bishop H6 again never forget about this
move especially when white lacks a dark
Spirit bishop and you win the queen and
notice how your queen supports that
Bishop on H6 very easy to forget about
if you don't know this idea beforehand
so that's one possibility but you can
also play the simple move Knight takes
C3
and
well if white recaptures with the queen
who can tell me the strongest move for
black let's see who has understood the
spirit of the accelerated dragon yeah
you just play E4 right anytime you can
open up your Bishop like this with Tempo
you absolutely should you're also
opening up the center white is totally
busted and in a position like this you
should never hesitate to sacrifice The
Exchange just take on F3
and after Bishop takes f8 even if you
play this very primitively and recapture
I see the engine is giving like Bishop
takes they're tactical moves but even if
you just take you should understand that
this position is indefensible for white
because just look at the king's
placement in the center again white
can't Castle because of Bishop H6 that's
important and if white recaptures well
for example you can deliver a check
you could snap off the pawn on B2 Queen
E8 is never dangerous because you could
cover with the bishop that's the beauty
of the Theon ghetto
and otherwise White's position just
totally and completely falls apart Rook
C1 just Bishop D7 and rookie a bring the
last reserves into the game and you can
analyze this more on your own but your
intuition should be pointing in the
right direction here you should
understand that this is totally
overwhelming for black if white plays
Bishop takes Rook here again you play
Queen takes f8
and it's the same drill Queen takes C3
E4 is crushing white could keep eating
but you're gonna keep checking Queen
before check C3 Queen takes B2 and
obviously this runs into just Chuck made
in two moves easy to calculate these
lines
and if white plays Pawn takes C3 then
this is very valuable for us because
white can essentially never Castle Queen
inside the king is now stuck in the
center but I would still play the move
Bishop H6 here not necessarily to keep
the king in the center just to bring the
bishop to a more active Square
and now a move like Queen C5 looks
really good tying light down to C3 the
bishop comes out and here white can
already resign that's because White's
position is completely in shambles Queen
C4 Queen E3
and this is why I love you know
Sicilians because they teach you how to
attack and you're going to get these
types of positions a lot if you're like
under 2200
so in any case just a couple of lines to
stimulate your creative juices
um what lessons can we derive from this
analysis well first of all you should be
very cautious of this situation where
the Bishops are staring at each other
and you should not be giving away your
dark sweat Bishop for White's Bishop
unless you know you have to or there's
some extenuating circumstance so you
would rather play E5 and temporarily
close the bishop down then trade on D4
don't be afraid to sacrifice The
Exchange on f8 in most circumstances
even if you let White Castle Queen side
that sacrifice is still warranted
and the other thing is just the sort of
basic philosophy behind the accelerated
is that you're trying to save a Tempo on
the Move D6 which you don't play until
like five moves deep into the main line
so anyways F3 we play D5
as we've already discussed Knight takes
C6 BC and E5 here makes no sense because
here you actually just have Knight G4
and this is just a disaster for white
and our opponent's move now is the time
for an ig4 just concrete thinking allows
us to understand that in this position
we have this additional resource Bishop
H6 which now hopefully nobody who
watches the speeding game will ever
forget about looking for Bishop H6 in uh
dragon positions and in general in a lot
of Sicilians this bishop H6 idea is so
easily missable by a lot of players for
some reason I've noticed that players
miss a lot of tactics on this specific
diagonal which involves the queen on D2
and a newly castled king and a bishop
appearing on this diagonal because I
think in in players as minds they tend
to sort of assume that if Ian Caro
Bishop can't move from its fiancated
Square Bishop H6 is unnatural I have an
example of this from an old game that I
played I just remembered this
so take a look at this game
and in this game I played the night ORF
and I played a terrible line
but I had analyzed it beforehand and it
relies on a trap which my opponent fell
into
this is a game from 2005.
I was a knight or a player back then and
I was a night or flare until I was a GM
so my opponent played Bishop E3 this is
called the English attack of the night
off I played Knight G4 which is a move
that is still played it's it was very
popular in the early 2000s I mean
Kasparov was playing it Chris shook a
lot of night or play nvl was a big
Knight G4 guy nowadays E5 which I play
myself is more popular
but anyways this is beside the point so
we followed the main line and here the
main move is I believe Bishop to G7 but
I had analyzed the move H5 with the
obvious threat of H4 my opponent sees it
he goes H3
forcing the Knight back this line is
garbage it's like plus minus but here's
the rub Queen D2
now Bishop to H6 in one Fell Swoop
and my opponent very confidently castles
Queen side
now he does not miss the move G4
he saw them with G4 in and of itself
because white can block that with Bishop
F4 right the same motif
but what did he miss and here by the way
black actually can also win the piece
but it's a much inferior version here
than it is to switch up the move order
what's the move that my opponent missed
yeah so you start with E5
and the point is that once the Knight
moves you're able to play G4 and win the
queen he tries Knight F3 which is
resilient G4 and Knight G5 and now it's
very easy for black to blunder I think a
lot of players might think this is the
move but it's not because the Knight
moves in and simultaneously defends G5
where should our Knight go and this is a
really pretty move where should our
Knight drop down to
yeah back but where H7 is Right Knight
H7 is the only good move
because you want to add attackers to the
G5 Knight and if white plays H4 then you
just take on G5
and obviously if F4 that's the other
point you on passant him white can keep
putting pieces on the diagonal but
ultimately he's going to lose his Queen
my opponent ended up giving up the full
night and I ended up winning the game
this was in 1800.
so just keep these ideas in mind
whichever Sicilian you play I know not
everybody who watches the speedrun is
necessarily going to play my
recommendations but hopefully you can
borrow at least some of the ideas to
your own openings
all right back to the game well there
isn't too much to talk about truth be
told once our opponent blunders now here
white could have perhaps mitigated some
of the damage by moving the bishop for
example here
but this position still looks like
garbage to me because I just I don't
think we need to talk about this too
much because F2 is hanging Rook B8 is
coming if you can get white to play B3
well first of all here you can just take
the pot so you could analyze this a
little bit on your own here the last
chance for white to stay in the game was
Bishop E3
but I think this is borderline lost I
think this position is still losing
first of all we hit the three Pawn
forcing another passive move now we go
Rook B8 and your goal is to induce B3
and I think a lot of players they might
think well what is the point of putting
your pieces on the B file if white can
just block it with B3 well the point is
that after B3 is played the Knight has
been softened up tremendously and you
can now re you could bring the bishop
back to home base or and but I would
first play a move like Queen C5 to
pressure the Knight with a queen
and also the A3 square has been weakened
tremendously so it's a Swiss cheese
situation on the dark squares and the
double Wham is that white lacks a dark
squared Bishop to defend these squares
so that's why in the long run white is
completely busted here even though it
might not be totally obvious to you
immediately here
Queen D4 doesn't work just take it
because the pawn is pinned we're still
on age six okay white plays King B1 I
would drop the bishop back hit the
Knight
and once the Knight is force back of
course you have the typical idea A5 A4
or you could open up the center with D5
and bring this bishop out to F5 this
position basically plays itself
classic right triangle so
Bishop B3 would have been more resilient
now the game is not totally over I would
with white I think it's over after Queen
E2 here there's just nothing left to
talk about if I was playing white here I
think the last chance is to give up the
bishop for a pawn
and then perhaps try a move like H3 to
keep this Knight confined the Knight
actually currently has no squares but
the move that I spotted here for black
is Queen to H4 we can eliminate the
attacker and I still think the it's
completely winning and if white plays 92
then our Knight is able to evacuate via
this new Square which is opened up in
Knight C4
the engine by the way recommends the
move a G3 here
to solidify this pawn and now it gives
D5 e takes D5 and slightly okay now just
Rook B8 so you open up the center by
sacking a pawn and now you attack B2
and uh if King B1
yeah just CD Knight T5 and just Bishop
E6 develop your pieces
Bishop G2 Knight C4 oh yeah this is just
crashing
easy clap yeah no white white is white
is totally completely lost but after our
opponent played Queenie two uh the one
Pitfall to avoid of course is not to
take on F4 automatically understanding
the concept of diminishing returns right
you shouldn't be rushing to take
additional pawns here the bishop is
hanging black is still winning after
Bishop B5 you shouldn't Panic if you
blunder like this and of course you
should keep your Bishop at all costs
this position is still completely
winning actually it's plus four because
you're up a pawn and you have a raging
attack
but
of course taking on D4 uh obvious the
need for that
and here Queen B6 is I think very
accurate here it took me a while because
I wanted to to be as clinical as
possible I think Queen C5 is fine I'm
sure the engine will have a more precise
uh move in mind it's giving D5 which is
also good the one thing to remember is
that this is not forced mate white can
defend with King A1
and one thing I've seen some players
forget about is in a situation like this
A5 is not as good as it looks because
once you play A4 it looks like you're
winning but white can keep the situation
clogged with before
I can keep the situation clogged with
before
and Rook B8 is winning here but it's a
little bit cumbersome and suddenly
things get a little bit sharper than
they're supposed to
and by the way Bishop back to G7 with
the idea Queen B2 check doesn't work
because once The Rook takes the King has
that escape Square on B1 so for that
reason I wanted to keep the king stuck
on C1 and that's why I played Queen C5
threatening Queen A3 forcing The Rook
away and now you open up the center you
play on all sides of the board and I
think the nicest win was Bishop to G4
yeah it is the top move also because you
keep the square
occupied
and while you keep it occupied you buy
yourself a Tempo to bring the Rook to d8
to keep it occupied once again
so that's why not Bishop F5 because here
you're not covering the D1 Square
obviously you're still completely
winning but King D1 staves off the
Checkmate for a little bit longer so
Bishop G4 rook d8 and our opponent
resigned again Bishop D3 the nicest win
is Rook takes you through but for the
context of the speed run I would
recommend that you just take with the
pawn don't you know look for Adventures
when there are none if you're up a piece
and you're mating don't sacrifice unless
you're you've calculated to Checkmate
and you're absolutely sure that you know
the sacrificial approach leads to the
desired result
so
that's about it folks and again slightly
underwhelming from a theory standpoint
but we're only 1800 you know we're going
until 22 2300 so I'm sure that we're
going to get a lot of more theoretically
topical accelerated games as we go along
and you know that's the whole philosophy
of the speed run the further along we
get the more attention I pay to
mainstream Theory the more time that we
dedicate to specific Theory as opposed
to general concepts this is only our
second accelerated dragon game so I'm
still hitting on the kind of General
ideas and hopefully you found this
expose to be helpful
on that note folks let's end wow four
and a half hours can't believe it
this was a lot longer than anticipated I
have
two hours to do a bunch of different
things so I gotta get to work I will
stream on Thursday I also have PCL and
then I probably will do a stream with
bow Tes
thank you all uh for the support
every sub counts my goal is to hit
400 000 Subs by
by 20 by the start of 2024 it's a very
modest goal but you know
we're moving along
100 Subs at a time
but hopefully one day we can hit half a
million that would be a dream come true
every sub counts appreciate people's
support
and uh YouTube videos will be coming out
at a normal Pace in the next few days
have a great one and uh thanks for
hanging out
[Music]